my dear brothers alhamdulillah as
everyone knows that we have a small
Masjid and we're trying to raise money
because alhamdulillah we have a lot of
people attend to the Masjid especially
for our classes and jum so we need a
bigger time you saw there's many rubbish
outside blocking the people's path and
we open a madasa many families got
scared to bring their children into the
Masjid because of the Alle way you have
smoking drugs aldah teach
people Arabic language teach people
aldah we do da alhamdulillah many many
people except Islam alhamdulillah comes
to the m the de of Allah subhah waala
and we have printed many many lifl many
books defending the Islam calling people
to Islam teaching people Islam
alhamdulillah the situation isn't even
that bad but if you think this is bad
has been worse we' got boxes we've got
garbage we've got rats at time we've got
sometimes people just laying around
sleeping you know what I mean so
unfortunately the situation for isn't
the bestd but for those that are
wondering this is the reality of the
Masid we got Rubble B debris you know so
don't think that the situation that
we're in right now is the best of
situation it's not exactly plausible but
uh you know this is why we're asking you
know the people after Allah first and
foremost to donate generously and
immensely because we are in need of
donations blessed Ramadan to you the
viewers and likewise here we
are in as you all know how you last saw
us is how we still are and we want to
eventually
inal uh make our way out of this place
which isn't necessarily the best of
places you know it's a bit unfortunate
but we are here uh have a look it hasn't
changed the place hasn't
changed even it's got a little bit
clearer a little bit
clearer but this isn't exactly the best
of places to be especially in the month
of Ramadan his place
here you're going to be see praying
literally on this here we want a better
place we want a place where we could be
comfortable and you know be in vast
amounts of space alhamdulillah
especially for the kids and for the
people out there and the families so
have a quick walk with
me what we're dealing with look at the
stuff down
here I don't know
[Laughter]
we're still dealing with the
rubbish we want better
facilities it's not exactly the most
suitable of places to be this what we're
dealing with so don't forget us in your
donations you know
whoever builds a place or a home you
know a m to establish the worship of
Allah in this life Allah will build for
him a place meaning an abod in Paradise
for him you know a luxurious and if they
see after
after Al full of people smoking drugs
you know you understand literally
literally so imagine you be walking
literally down this this path here you
can see a rat jump through here or a man
here doing whatever he's doing this is
how is how narrow it is it's not
suitable at all alhamd this is what it
is families can't exactly come down here
Bob here
rubbish Asos you name it
alhamdulillah so don't forget us in your
donations and as you all know whatever
you put forth in the month of Ramadan
Allah will not forget that verely you'll
be recompensed either in this life or in
the afterlife as you all know the
investment of the afterlife is the best
investment could it be our last Ramadan
Allah knows best we always ask to bless
us with more blessed Ramadan to
come for